it's a good part I like that part this
is a this is a lot this is a look that's
happening today there's a lot of choices
that have been made all stacked upon
themselves hi guys my name is grace
Helbig if you don't know now you know
your life is different now you see the
title of this video it's time for an
October favorites these are the things
that I have liked slightly more than
other things this month so let's just do
it first yeah yeah say yeah yeah say
yeah yeah say yeah this is a Top Gun
onesie technically Halloween costume
that I got from Amazon Prime now when I
ordered a bunch of props for a recent
video you saw it if you watch my videos
and I loved it so much I own a lot of
onesies but for some reason this one
makes me feel so say so strong so stupid
in a fun way since I bought it since I
purchased it since I invested in it I
have almost every single night been
putting this on before I fall asleep
dancing around my house to either
Hamilton or Joey on and just having a
delightful adult time by myself with my
dog ten out of ten
would recommend max let's talk about the
elephant in the room yeah yes yeah yeah
say yeah yeah say yeah this is what's on
my lips now I know this is dramatic I
don't normally do this but I really like
this this is a Kylie lip kit I talked
last month about the fact that I like
these Kylie lip kits I bought three of
them I mentioned dirty peach last time
which was like a dirty peach color this
one however this one's called leo and I
like it and I put it on my lips today
and I can't stop looking at my lips I
feel like I'm pronouncing everything so
intensely when your lip color is this
color it's fun for fall it's fun in
small doses it's the pumpkin spice of
lip stain you see it look oh yeah next
yeah yeah say yeah yeah say yeah hey I
say in talking about lip stains I love
this I'm really I'm trying to work on my
inflection being appropriate in the
right areas
so doesn't doesn't work out this is tart
East
lip paint eye tart and it's in the color
cry-cry maybe this has been in the
favorites videos lot of things in this
favorites video that I think have been
in favorites videos already classic it's
like this orange ready color I like it a
lot
I feel like it's appropriate for right
now because pumpkins and Halloween
orange aren't you glad I recommended an
orange lip stain neck yeah yeah say yeah
yeah say yeah yeah say yeah this is
gonna feel like I'm sponsored by Kylie
cosmetics but I'm not I'm just [ __ ]
fascinated so following Kylie on
snapchat and I saw that she was
releasing a new line of Chi shadows her
eye shadow orc eyeshadow palette and I
went online I ordered the bronze palette
which is the one that already exists I
guess she's releasing another one soon
and I really like it these are the
colors I don't know why I feel like bad
for liking it but I really like it I've
been using all of these shades lately
because I'm fascinated by orange
those are pretty shade those look like
leaves changing in the fall which I
don't get out here in Los Angeles and
I'm from New Jersey and so maybe that's
what I'm displacing no not at all I can
look at screen savers if I really want
that feeling look how sad she's so sad
she's crying eyeshadows yeah how can you
not give her money yeah yeah this oh I
just threw it around
I'm extremely athletic if any of you had
any questions about that yeah yeah see
yeah see yeah see this is
and my ex's sculpt and highlight brow
contour I like testing out brow products
and this I bought at CVS the other day
it's in the color ash brown medium beige
and basically on one side it's a brow
pencil
oh she thrilling and on the other side
it's a highlight color and I like almost
all double-ended things I said almost
all your perverts you filthy nasty women
perverts
I like this a lot I think the main
reason I like it is that I finally found
the right eyebrow color for me because a
lot of really great eyebrow products
that I just bought the wrong color of I
think it's a good product where you
today you can see it wow yeah yeah yeah
yeah say yeah yeah say yeah I guess is
alcohol free ma just kidding ha ha
strannix single-step acne control soft
textured pads what's the actual name of
this product soft touch pads pads with a
solution in them that you wipe over your
face and that cleans out your face
do not use them like makeup wipes these
are not meant to go over your eyes these
are pretty intense in terms of sting
factor I think that's why I like them so
much because I believe when things sting
my face that means that they're working
that's not the best scientific
philosophy to stand by but it's what I
do if I take all my makeup off and then
I throw one of these all over my face I
feel like it's much more cleansed qx--
now ya see ya see ya hey I see yes
speaking of things that sting double pun
this is from birth B's and it's a
blemish stick and it stings my face when
I use it this is supposed to be an
herbal blemish stick that you basically
roll over any blemishes you have on your
face after you've washed your face at
night or in the morning and it's
supposed to UM disappear them and a
little bit goes a long way I've used it
a bunch and it's barely gone down at all
it's available in
convenience store drugstores so that's
also why I like it so cute fun next yeah
yes yeah yeah say yeah I'll see you
again this is something I believe has
already been in a favorites video but I
don't know and I've been enjoying it
lately so I'm talking about it maybe
again what is this called
this is crest ProHealth HD something
it's a two-step toothpaste whitening
system thing I use Crest Whitestrips a
lot in the past and they my teeth I
think I've gotten more sensitive and so
they've kind of hurt or sting and my
gums are sensitive and so I started
using this toothpaste system and it
works really well for me it's a very
easy system it's two steps you brush
your teeth with this and then you brush
your teeth with this and you don't rinse
out your mouth
in between purifying cleanser helps
strip away plaque and then this is the
perfecting gel polishes and whitens it's
easy and I like it I get that smile next
yeah you see yeah you'll say yeah I'll
say yeah this is a candle that I bought
from Target it's from the Chesapeake Bay
candle company in the scent sandalwood
and it smells great I like the smell of
wood insert your Boehner jokes here I
don't like a lot of floral or soapy
scents you guys if you watch my videos
know this about me by now
I like more masculine musky scent it's
lasted a really long time it's pretty
pungent so you don't have to let it burn
for very long before your house smells
like sandalwood you can blow it out and
bring it into another room and instantly
like I have this in my kitchen I brought
it up here to my office and my whole
office smells like sandalwood now and it
hasn't been lit at all I also like that
it's in the such cute pin twisty marble
thing that you could probably rinse out
and reuse for something else oh my god
upcycle comm slash edu hashtag me future
well that's it for my favorites this
month
let me guys know what you are loving
this month I'm curious and I hope that
you guys
it through this video without being
totally distracted by this lip color I
know that I have looked in this
viewfinder so much more in this video
because of that then I have a lot of
other videos and I apologize do I
apologize me maybe
don't worry to subscribe to this YouTube
channel by clicking this button right
here if you enjoyed this at all on any
level or if you hated it just subscribe
you deserve it and that's it I don't
know ah heyo